the Joe Rogan experience I feel like
I've gained you know this is part of
what I was referring to earlier where I
said like you know we're learning to
dance and the party's almost over I I
feel I don't have kids
I've been around kids but I feel like
when I was in my 20s let's say I sort of
worked this out recently in
relationships that I think I think there
are three things there's attraction
there's compatibility and there's love
mm-hmm and I look at a lot of my
relationships with women they had two of
those mmm
always love yeah sometimes the the sex
was great and sometimes the
compatibility was great and very rarely
all three of those but I used to think
love was a really limited scarce
experience in life and the older I get
the more I feel like no love is I could
love anybody hmm if I spent enough time
with them and got to know them
I'd feel love for them right you know
that's not hard to find
it's it seems it's everywhere mm-hmm
when I was young I thought it was really
hard to find well for some people it is
you know some people it is it's hard to
find someone who loves them and some
people are burdened down like you're
you're very free in the sense that
because you have this unusual way of
making money
and you have you don't have a lot of
needs you don't need a lot of material
things some people are very burdened by
these needs you know and they're not
free and they're confined to a job and
it's very difficult for them to meet
anybody right and then they're also
stressed out all the time is a bills and
horseshit and then work politics and
work dynamics you know dealing with the
[ __ ] environment of the office yeah
and you got a boss that's an [ __ ]
who's like you know you have board
meetings and [ __ ] and everybody's got to
sit there and get cancer [ __ ] talks
you know the board table and some guys
what we got to do with this company you
know the matrix and I need you to be
here after work I need you you're here
9:00 to 5:00 I want to see a real
commitment I want to you know what I'm
wondering family 7 yeah what I'm leaving
at 7 I want to see you still here
working
yeah yeah no and then it's hard to meet
somebody it's hard to find love yeah
okay you're certainly you're right about
that I didn't really mean in a dating
sense so much is just like compassion
sense okay you know what I mean right
that everybody's lovable sure you know
like one of the things that I love doing
in my podcast is meeting somebody who's
never told their story before and never
even thought of their life in terms of a
narrative and in the course of the
podcast having them realize how [ __ ]
interesting they are and how interesting
their life is but I've had people like
break into tears and stuff you know
because they've never thought like no
one's ever asked right
you know everybody's interesting
everybody's got some kind of bizarre
story to tell
often they don't know it you know and I
feel the same way like everybody's
lovable every my talking about romantic
I know what you're saying you're just
like yeah and it and you reminded me of
when you're talking about seeing the
full person's life sometimes I've looked
at like women that I was with who were
you know 35 years old and I let see the
old lady in them mmm be moved by that
you know like you're gonna be a
beautiful old lady I'll be dead yeah I
see that I'm like I gotta get out of
here before she becomes an all day
I see menopause coming anybody angry
maybe [ __ ] I didn't even yeah no I know
what you're saying I know what you're
saying and I mean everybody's lovable to
somebody right I mean unless you're a
[ __ ] psychopath
[Applause]